>> Bret: IN A SENSE A WARTIME
PRESIDENT, WE WILL BE INVOKING
THE DEFENSE PRODUCTION ACT.
WE ARE SENDING UPON REQUEST THE
TWO HOSPITAL SHIPS BEING
PREPARED, MASSIVE SHIPS.
>> I HAVE DIRECTED THE HOSPITAL
SHIP’S MERCY AND COMFORT TO BE
PREPARED TO DEPLOY TO INCREASE
THE NATION’S MEDICAL CAPACITY
AND WE HAVE ALSO ALERTED A
VARIETY OF HOSPITALS TO BE
PREPARED TO DEPLOY AS NEEDED.
>> Bret: THE DEFENSE SECRETARY
ON OUR SHOW LAST NIGHT TALKING
ABOUT DEPLOYMENT OF U.S.
MILITARY ASSETS TO FIGHT THIS.
TAKING A LOOK AT THE NUMBERS,
TOTAL NUMBER OF CASES 7,663,
TOTAL DEATHS 115.
WORLDWIDE MORE THAN 21,408,700
DEATHS BUT TOTAL RECOVERED AT
THIS .83313.
THE DOW TAKING A BIG DIVE AND
RECOVERING A BIT, THE SENATOR
MOVING FORWARD WITH THE HOUSE
BILL TO FACE TWO.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE DOW SINCE THE
PRESIDENT’S ELECTION, TAKE A
LOOK AT THAT RISE AND THAT
DRAMATIC FALL WHEN THE
CORONAVIRUS HIT.
LET’S BRING IN OUR PANEL,
CHARLES HURT OPINION EDITOR FOR
"THE WASHINGTON TIMES,"
MARA LIASSON OF NATIONAL PUBLIC
RADIO AND STEVE HAYES EDITOR OF
THE DISPATCH.
WE ARE LOOKING AT WHAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS DOING, WE
HAVE SEEN THE SECOND PHASE
HEADED TO THE PRESIDENT’S DESK
AND IT SEEMS LIKE MORE IS ON THE
WAY, A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT MORE.
>> IT’S AN ENCOURAGING
DEVELOPMENT YOU HEARD THE
PRESIDENT DESCRIBED HIMSELF AS A
WARTIME PRESIDENT BECAUSE THAT’S
WHAT WE NEED FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION.
YOU NEED THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
SCRAMBLING TO CATCH UP TO THE
STATES AND THE KIND OF MEASURES
WE NOW SEE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT -- THEY ARE NOW
MOVING THE MILITARY SHIPS TO
PLACES THAT COULD BE A GOOD
OUTCOME.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE THEM MOVE ON
VENTILATORS, ADDITIONAL
PROTECTIVE GEAR FOR PHYSICIANS
AND HEALTH WORKERS TO MAKE SURE
THAT --
>> Bret: WE SHOULD GET OUR
HEADS AROUND THE FACT THAT THESE
NUMBERS ARE GOING TO EXPLODE AS
IN THE PLACE.
>> AT THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
BEEN TRYING TO PREPARE PEOPLE
FOR THAT.
WE HAVE BEEN FLYING BLIND UNLIKE
OTHER COUNTRIES WE DIDN’T TEST
MASSIVELY IN THE LAST TWO MONTHS
SINCE IT ARRIVED ON OUR SHORES.
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO GET TESTED
AND WE WILL FIND OUT HOW
WIDESPREAD THIS IS AND IT’S
GOING TO BE A SHOCK.
ON THE OTHER HAND, ONCE WE KNOW
WHO HAS IT IT’S GOING TO MAKE
SOCIAL DISTANCING MORE TARGETED.
AT LEAST WE WILL HAVE THE
ABILITY TO DO THAT, THAT’S WHAT
THEY WERE ABLE TO DO IN
SOUTH KOREA AND SINGAPORE.
WE WILL HAVE A BIG EXPLOSION AND
THEN IT WILL ALSO MAKE THE
FATALITY RATE GET SMALLER
BECAUSE WE WILL UNDERSTAND HOW
MANY PEOPLE HAVE IT AND HOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE DYING.
IN TERMS OF THE RESPONSE, I
THINK YOU WILL SEE THE RESPONSE
TODAY ALL ABOUT PAID SICK LEAVE,
FREE TESTING, NEXT IT’S GOING TO
BE ACTUAL CASH IN PEOPLE’S
POCKETS.
>> Bret: EXPANDS PAID SICK
LEAVE TO PEOPLE CARING FOR A
FAMILY MEMBER, EXTENDS
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE, BOOST
FOOD ASSISTANCE, PROVIDE SCHOOL
MEALS FOR CHILDREN SINCE SCHOOLS
HAVE CLOSED AND PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FUNDING FOR
MEDICAID.
IF WE ARE READY FOR PHASE THREE
AND THAT IS JUST A CHECK TO ALL
AMERICANS.
ANDREW YANG LEFT THE RACE A
MONTH AGO AND HE’S SAYING THERE
IS MY THOUSAND DOLLARS A MONTH
MY IDEA.
IT MAY ACTUALLY COME TO PASS, WE
DON’T KNOW THE NUMBERS YET.
>> IT’S KIND OF AMAZING WHEN YOU
LOOK AROUND AND YOU SEE THESE
ORDERS COMING FROM GOVERNMENTS
TO SHUT DOWN RESTAURANTS, TO
SHUT DOWN GATHERING PLACES OF
TEN PEOPLE OR MORE COMING AT THE
STATE LEVEL OR LOCAL LEVELS --
IT’S KIND OF AMAZING.
THOSE PEOPLE THAT WORK IN THOSE
ENVIRONMENTS ARE GOING TO BE THE
ONES THAT ARE HARDEST HIT.
THAT’S A REAL THING.
THIS WHOLE TIME WE HAVE BEEN IN
THIS WAITING GAME AND IT’S HARD
TO DO BECAUSE MUCH OF THE
STORIES THAT WE READ ABOUT OUR
STORIES ABOUT EFFECTS OF
QUARANTINES AND THEY’VE TAKEN
THE STEPS AS PRECAUTIONARY
MEASURES AS OPPOSED TO ACTUAL
RESULTS OF ACTUAL VIRUS.
IT’S PARTICULARLY TRUE OUTSIDE
OF PLACES LIKE NEW YORK AND
WASHINGTON AND RURAL PARTS OF
THE COUNTRY WHERE WE SEE THAT
GREAT REPORT WE JUST HAD ABOUT
PEOPLE PURCHASING GUNS AND
AMMUNITION.
WHAT THAT IS MORE THAN ANYTHING,
IT’S A VERY HEALTHY AMERICAN
INDICATION THAT PEOPLE TRUST
THEMSELVES TO TAKE CARE OF
THEMSELVES AND THEIR NEIGHBORS
MORE THAN THEY TRUST GOVERNMENTS
WHETHER IT’S THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT OR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
I THINK THE IMPORTANT THING AT
THIS POINT, WHEREVER YOU ARE ON
YOUR LEVEL OF CONCERN ABOUT THIS
IS IT’S KIND OF LIKE THE SAYING
IF YOU FIND YOURSELF WALKING
THROUGH, DON’T STOP.
WHEREVER YOU ARE ON THE
CONCERNED SCALE, WHATEVER YOU
CAN DO AT THIS POINT TO KEEP
GOING TO MARCH THROUGH THE BEAR
MARKET, TO MARCH THROUGH THIS IS
A GOOD THING.
>> Bret: OBVIOUSLY
CAPITOL HILL IS A FEW MORE THAN
TEN PEOPLE, I’M GETTING WORD
RIGHT NOW THAT CONGRESSMAN MARIO
DIAZ HAS TESTED POSITIVE FOR
CORONAVIRUS, HE SELF QUARANTINED
AND HE ISN’T GOING BACK TO
SOUTH FLORIDA WITH HIS WIFE BUT
JUST PASSING THAT ALONG.